le reportage de nicole candu landois et
jean lumeau
quand santé passé libration ses émotions
ses petits coeurs qui s'affolent ses
sensations ses filtres l'amour
je vois si alexandre cet écrivain retiré
dans une hacienda au mexique semble si
désespérée c'est parce qu'il a cru un
moment une renaissance par un amour qui
le déçoit
et si l'acteur est si complice avec
l'auteur réalisateur c'est que peut-être
alexandre leur ressemble j'ai commencé
avec ce scénario avant avant de
rencontrer alain delon du jour je les
rencontre et c'est d'ailleurs en euros
et s'est donc adapté et il ya des
moments dans le film une vieille
écrivain mais pour réduire acteurs
quand j'ai débarqué ici je me disais est
tellement loin de tout que même la
prochaine il se mettra du temps à
arriver
je n'en suis plus si sûr
en face d'alain delon un autre monstre
sacré lauren bacall
elle interprète une amie de l'écrivain
mystérieuse lucide et protectrice
que pense-t-elle de son partenaire alain
delon n'a pas affecté les mots et pas
celle 14 avec toulon n'a pas comme ça
pense au travail et lé monde et ça c'est
bien d'autant plus qu'il sait aussi être
tendre sur le plateau et jouer la
passion pour une actrice venus
d'ailleurs qui pourrait changer sa vie
dans ce film lyrique